messieurs je vous souhaite la bienvenue
sur le plateau dès mercredi de
l'information chaque mercredi à 20h30 en
effet lyon paris liverpool que se
passe-t-il à la périphérie dans les
banlieues de ces grandes villes pour
qu'on en soit arrivé à ce jeu de
massacre de génération qui se cognent
contre le béton et le chômage qui
s'offrent des soirées de sa cache du
meuble de mise à feu de voiture ou bien
de matraquage d'individus bref qu'ils
sont les loubards des grandes banlieues
il ya bien longtemps déjà mais sans
doute personne n'a été n'at-il été
suffisamment attentif que les éducateurs
que les juges ont interpellé la société
en montrant qu'on ne pouvait pas
continuer à ignorer d'un côté les
origines de ce problème et puis de
l'autre a condamné par classe entière
des jeunes mal intégrés à la société
d'ailleurs est-il fondamentalement
raisonnable d'entasser les ex plus dense
et périphérie de ville à la périphérie
de la consommation aussi sans s'attendre
un jour ou l'autre à en payer le prix
le reportage d'eric gilbert jean-pierre
abou tony bosco et jules bernard signé à
d'abord pour but d'essayer de comprendre
de regarder d'observer ils ont donc
passé une semaine à la cité des canigou
à nanterre notamment près de paris nous
n'avons pas voulu aller à lyon
villeurbanne qui est une cité en crise
comme vous le savez dans ce domaine
parce que nous avons pris beaucoup de
précautions pour ne pas céder à la
tentation du spectaculaire un
spectaculaire qui auraient été exploités
même à notre insu dans la mesure où l'un
où l'on a toujours tendance à valoriser
à opérer une surenchère devant une
caméra
les témoignages que vous allez entendre
et voir ont peut-être vous déranger sans
doute vous impatientez par moments
encore cette fois encore une fois c'est
mal nantis font partie de l' équilibre
de notre société nous vivons dedans et
le premier devoir des journalistes que
nous sommes et d'observer pour vous
donner à comprendre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
[Musique]
bien comprendre ce qui s'est passé à
lyon qui s'est passé à lyon ça faisait
longtemps qu'on pensait que ça risquait
d'arriver à dire qu'on peut pas faire
une politique d'éviction une population
parce que c'est ça ou de mise à l'écart
d'une population à travers l'expulsion à
travers le chômage etc sans qu'un jour
ou l'autre on en paye les conséquences
au plan social bon c'est ce qui s'est
passé à lyon c'est ça
si ce juge avait dit vrai des vénissieux
il devait y en avoir d'autres en france
nous sommes donc partis en voyage à
l'intérieur des banlieues les cités
traversées se ressemblent et août
le plus souvent elle était coincée entre
des autoroutes et des voies ferrées
après une semaine d'enquêté
nous en avons choisi une ni pire ni
meilleur que les autres
la cité des canigou à nanterre 3600
personnes la population d'un gros
village dans huit cuves de béton à
quelques stations de métro de paris une
forte proportion d'immigrés comme dans
toutes les autres banlieues
nous sommes arrivés au canigou un
dimanche après midi ne se passait rien
tout semblait même si calme que nous
avons failli rebrousser chemin
et puis dans un petit square de
locataires jouer paisiblement aux boules
aussi avant d'aller chercher ailleurs
avons-nous décidé tout de même de leur
demander leur avis évitez la cité qu'est
ce que vous pensez des jeunes ici des
cons pourquoi pourquoi pas s'il ya trop
brouillon dans le quartier ils sont ils
sont là ils sont là que pour piller les
cas pouvoir filmer ses oreilles laissez
moi tranquille s'il vous plaît je joue
aux boules s'il vous plaît monsieur
dégagé dégagé
si vous savez le soir on peut plus
sortir
pourquoi ouvre d'attaquer les femmes les
femmes âgées se consacre au quartier
devient vraiment triste pour faire
quelque chose
les agents il peut plus rien faire je
voulais qu'ils cherchent qui cherchent
par tous ceux des roms
je me demandais départ on pensait que
les jeunes c'est la police qui doit s'en
occuper
ben autant que possible parce que les
personnes ici et quand sourkov réduite y
costumes ou alors c'est un désastre on
n'a jamais fait ça de notre temps on
peut s'amuser tout de même 100 gr c est
vous ne vous êtes jamais demandé
pourquoi ils cassaient nom ne le
demandent pas parce que parce que quand
on dit aux parents dit donnez lui votre
gosse qu'il aime c'est le fauga qui
s'amusent
et vous avez des enfants à l'école mais
kastoria il faudra le groupe q alors si
les enfants des autres dans le siphon
sahraouis dans le temps n'ont été sept
enfants 1 quand on rentre à la maison
avec un ballon plus d'apporter n'est pas
nôtre nous demander où c'est qu'on était
juste et qu'on avait eu le ballon mais
pour raconter un tas de bêtises vous
décollez changer ou n'importe quoi tu
m'appelles ramener ballon et maintenant
les jambes un négociant tête d'une
mobylette moi c'est mon papa qui me l'a
donnée moi je vais vous dire un petit
truc moi on m'a volé ma mobylette ici
maroun mobile est ici un mabhouh un
round mobile est alors qu'il y avait des
gars qui étaient là on va démonter
maraude mobylette et géra schéma roule
ma ville est un cadre un quart d'heure
après faire payer moi et tout le monde
rigolait qu'est-ce qui brûlent vers les
mobiles dans une moto
ils ont brûlé
surpris par la violence du thon nous
avons continué espérant trouver des
réponses plus nuancées
c'est parce que l'argent
la voiture peut pas laisser dehors rien
on voit l'intérieur on la casse qui se
bat l'intérieur où je perds je sais pas
vous laisser en permanence un chien dans
votre voiture avant de plonger devant
boulanger il ya un jeune enfant qui
passe lui dis gentiment
normalement il ya un autre derrière il
va se faire
qu'est ce que voulait faire un tour à
moi j'ai vu nérac en plein jour à 11h30
une portugaise capitaux bâtiment comment
elle s'appelle au sixième étage même
qu'au manque à l'appel
et qu'est ce qui s'est passé le jeune
intéressante mais moi j'ai couvert après
mais j'ai pas encore assez vite elle
péchait tirer son porte monnaie
oui derrière ils résistent encore planer
derrière les idées raid x et c'était un
dimanche matin
est ce que c'est vrai que les gens qui
ont des armes maintenant ici même une
personne ici je ne dirai pas le nom mais
qui a même tenté de qui a même tiré sur
la pierre sur le volet vous pensez que
c'est une solution question par les
armes mais je ne pense pas non pas par
les heures donc ce sera et c'est
véritablement catastrophe sur les armes
le réciter decani bout nous avons été
surpris par le nombre de chiens
presque chaque locataire en possèdent à
eux de se protéger des cambrioleurs les
adultes et les jeunes se croisent
uniquement le samedi et le dimanche
les vieux comme ils disent ont installé
un bar au rez de chaussée d'un des
immeubles ils boivent du pastis et joue
aux boules
les jeunes eux déambulent par petits
groupes les uns et les autres s'est vite
avec méfiance
dans cette cité un habitant sur deux a
moins de 20 ans et la moitié des jeunes
sont des immigrés quand il doit un peu
d'argent ils vont jouer au flipper ou
aux tierces électronique dans un bar qui
longe la route nationale
en semaine les adultes et les jeunes
n'ont pas les mêmes horaires et adultes
se lèvent tôt le matin pour aller
travailler
les jeunes vivent surtout la nuit et
dorment tard dans la matinée vers cinq
heures du soir on les voit apparaître le
par petits bouts à proximité de leur
club en ce sens la cité les caniveaux
est privilégiée par rapport à d'autres
cités quatre animateurs ont créé un club
où la plupart des jeunes viennent
l'après midi entre 6h et 8h jouer aux
cartes au ping pong aux échecs à tour de
rôle l'un d'entre eux gerba où ils
consomment des boissons non-alcoolisées
pour le club est très important c'est
l'endroit où ils savent que des copains
vont les écouter lorsque comme ils le
disent ils sont dans la merde
les jeunes cassent d'accord mais qu'est
ce qu'ils ont comme loisir ici ils ont
rien geste fort c'est une minorité
seulement des jeunes picasso manet que
minorité qui gère et on généralise on a
souvent tendance à généraliser ici les
vieux plus tôt moi j'ai entendu lui
autrefois l'ena qui disait les attentats
ils jettent des bouteilles sur nous ils
cassent nos jeunes les boulistes tout ça
on leur castor
moi je sais que moi ce que j'ai vu j'ai
jamais vu un attentat contre les
boulistes
c'est faux ce qu'ils disent ce qu'ils
disent lassés pour ceux qui préfèrent
c'est pour nous achever les jeunes nous
parce qu'il n'y a jamais eu d'attentât
mais moi je sais que je suis passé mille
fois une heure du matin 5 heures du
matin tout ça devant mon pas mon porsche
jamais j'ai reçu une bouteille sur la
tête ne veulent pas essayer de voir
veulent pas essayer de comprendre dge
pour eux c'est tous des délinquants
tous sauf leur fils celui qui te dire à
tous les jeunes ceux des délinquants il
dire à tous les jeunes sauf mon fils
croit son fils talent spoerri
en fin de compte son fils il vient avec
nous si la nôtre agit bien avec nous
comme tu trouveras une merde devant gpo
avec le risque est capable savez ce que
je fais je ramasse désolé d'avoir sapé
rien devant de l'adresse mais j'aimerais
passer j'ai réfléchi et wayne rooney
christophe il faut les comprendre et les
façons les 900 moi je vous je voudrais
bien que je vous y avez votre côté ou
viré après vous pouvez parler de prédire
les vieux les vieux l'appartement et
l'appartement
pour marier pour rien dire moi je vous
dis pas les moyens dit le mot viol xm
partir les gens de la cité
enfin les honnêtes gens en ont marre ils
en ont marre ils se croyaient moi que si
je vous disais c'est quoi marre de ce
qui se passe qu'est des vols dans les
voitures des voix dans les caves des
cambriolages
ils en ont marre mais là non non mais
pourquoi soit le plus cohérent et un peu
ils ne distinguent pas si c'est toi qui
vous met tous dans le même panier
on connaît une partie des gens des
jeunes des voleurs on les connaît et la
police aussi les connaît mais la police
fermait à oui bon ça je vous le dis et
gens que je suis bien placée pour lui à
la police de fermer les yeux pour la
bonne raison que certains servent
d'indicateur et entre c'est vrai c'est
pareil à 8h le lendemain nous avons
voulu voir les cavs qui d'après leurs
propriétaires étaient payés
régulièrement pour être franc nous
n'avons pas eu l'impression de pénétrer
dans un coupe gorge
malgré quelques cadenas arrachés
mais cette exploration des sous sols et
des couloirs nous a fait découvrir une
autre caractéristique de la cité son
bruit incessant répercuter d'étagé en
étage
[Musique]
mais toujours du bruit comme ça ici le
chien le bruit des outils machines tout
à l'heure que sa tef ça me serait
difficile de dans un endroit où il ya
pénurie parce que j'étais n'ont pas
l'habitude depuis que je suis tout petit
j'entends toujours un peu moins de béton
aussi être béton ont continué tue 5 6 à
8 ans tu vois que du béton autour de toi
c'est difficile c'est monsieur le maire
est ce que sur le plan urbanisme ce
n'est déjà pas aberrant d'avoir
construit ces sites est de cette manière
là aberrant je ne pense pas mais nous ne
prétendons pas avoir fait dans le passé
le meilleur bannissement qui soit nous
concevons plus aujourd'hui l'urbanisme
de la même façon qu'il y a vingt ans
ceci étant il a fallu à une époque
répondre à des besoins urgents et
notamment avec l'existence à nanterre de
granby dont il parmi les plus grands des
airs de la région parisienne et cette
cité en l'occurrence a été la première
construite à titre définitif pour
participer à l'effort de résorption des
minots certaines des images qui vont
suivre peuvent choquer en face de la
cité côté route se trouve la maison de
nanterre
ce qui accueille les vieux les plus
démunis ceux qui finissent leur vie sans
rien nous n'avons pas cherché à faire
des raccourcis douteux mais cette
proximité est l'une des réalités
il ne faut pas fabriquer des mondes
d'exclus nous disait le juge des enfants
mais précisément cette cité cet hospice
ne sont ils pas déjà deux mondes
d'exclus face à face
ici qu'est ce que c'est une grande
grange ou mais beaucoup beaucoup
personnes l'école mais personne n'est
plus comment dire comment il ya beaucoup
d'ouvriers beaucoup d'émigrés bon c'est
maintenant les cités sont réduits à
tassin et on les met là dedans et qu'on
s'occupe d'eux on les a casé ça y est on
a fait notre boulot ça ne peut plus on
les laisse les jeunes ont l'impression
d'être un peu partout ici parquet non
c'est pas le ghetto quand même c'est pas
y'a pas un fils de barbelés tout autour
de la cité un an tu sors tu rentres tu
fais ce que tu veux mais enfin quand tu
vois ses grands bâtiments sans aucune
vis de ses grands porsche ses bancs en
pierre
qu'est ce que ça apporte rien du tout le
seul mois et le seul moment discrétion
c'est quand on descend un ballon et que
tout le monde tape dedans
là il ya tout le monde qui vient là on
lui même les gens par la fenêtre il
regarde le méné match de foot c'est pour
dire la distraction que ça porte un
match de football dans une cité celle ci
s'est beaucoup pour moi j'ai la chance
de connaître de milieux en allant à mon
école et puis en revenant le soir à ma
cité donc je connais deux milieux je
peux établir un équilibre quand même bon
mais j'ai la chance de connaître ses
deux milieux ménat qui n'ont pas la
chance de connaître connaissent que la
cité c'est tout mais il y en a qui font
le premier pas vers toi mais c'est aussi
de les aider sans ça c'est pas la peine
de vivre ici un ca les bras pas mais une
fois l'exemple et comment les nouvelles
les nouveaux habitants
comme il y en a qui ont été déboutés
d'un avis d'ici ils sont partis sont pas
restés longtemps ce parti sont pas
compris ils ont pas voulu s'adapter
alors des qui montre ici ils n'aiment
pas les communistes nobin peu qu'ils
restent dans leur coin qui font comment
qui font juste il rentre bâtiment ils
prennent leur voiture ils repartent quoi
ils vont boulot c'est tout ils voient
les gens ils ne voient ils font juste
bonjour mes toiles seront pas parler
alors c'est pour sa force légale ils en
ont marre pour ça qu'il ya entre les
jeunes
entre nous bon nous les jeunes de mon
âge me réussit à l'ensemble mais ça ça
les autres les grandes personnes non ça
marche pas comprennent pas les adultes
sont excédés non pas j'avais l'ird et
finalement de d'actes graves de
délinquance mais sont excédés par une
multiplication de petits chapardage
d'ennuis sur la voiture de cyclomoteur
volé de ski chaque chose en soi n'est
pas quelque chose d'extrêmement grave
mais c'est cette continuité dans cette
série de cette ambiance générale c'est
ça qui c'est ça qui fait monter une
tension assez considérable là dessus
là dessus il ya peut-être aussi au
départ une petite erreur c'est à dire
que moi je vois comment marche la cité
de nanterre elles ont été construites à
une époque et ils sont venus à ce moment
là un type de population c'est à dire
pratiquement ils viennent à ce moment là
des gens qui ont des enfants petits et
puis
quinze ans après on se retrouve ou dix
ans après on se retrouve effectivement
une explosion dans ces cités avec une
population adolescente très très
important qui forcément se regroupent et
une poussière un adulte qui commence à
se sentir mal à l'aise par rapport à
toutes ces jeunes en plus avec tout le
phénomène actuel bon c'est vrai pour ces
jeunes là ya pas de travail ils en
trouvent pas facilement les stages sont
mal adaptés pour cette population donc
pratiquement ils sont là dehors à
traînaillé bons et il ya un rapport de
force qui s'institue
[Musique]
ce jour-là mustapha se rendait à l'
agence nationale pour l'emploi nous
avons dissimulé notre caméra à
l'intérieur du bureau pour enregistrer
le dialogue
c'est pour l'inscrire cabinet dentaire
oui j'avais une crise d'autorité dont on
pense à la carte de résidence j'en ai
pas besoin d'une copie d'un tri
française lors celle un doute c'est avec
l âge de 18 ans u13 vous êtes né ici son
territoire avec les connaissez comme
importe quelle nationalité pour vous
optez parce que jusqu'à 18 ans bon il
considère que si vous n'êtes ni argent
ni 63 sa renseignez-vous comme serrières
parce que là
c'est plutôt longue de l'a300 je peux
pas travailler alors ah ben moi je sais
pas où c'est beaucoup quand vous
inscrire si vous n'avez pas d'une de ses
pièces en remercie
mustapha est né en france en 1963 c'est
à dire après l'indépendance de l'algérie
il a aujourd'hui 18 ans il faut qu'ils
choisissent entre la nationalité
française et la nationalité algérienne
l'algérie ne reconnaît pas la double
nationalité pour être inscrit à l'
agence nationale pour l'emploi
il faudrait donc qu'il renonce
définitivement à la nationalité
algérienne a ses racines
ce sacrifice du paraît inutile il sait
que ses copains qui ont pris une carte
d'identité française
non pas pour autant trouver du travail
dans la cité des dizaines de jeunes
refusent ce choix pour les employeurs
pour la police il se retrouve sans
papiers
[Musique]
si vous avez poussé problème aussi on a
vu ça tout à l'heure les problèmes de
papiers pour trouver du travail puisque
le travail c'est très important dans la
vie que vous avez c'est parce que
beaucoup d'entre vous ne veulent pas
choisir nos nations étaient français si
j'ai bien compris pourquoi est ce que
voulaient pas choisir le cd française
est ce qu'on peut nous expliquer ce
problème pourquoi est ce que tu te poses
une question nous ça face à nous
français c'est un test de français
je
quand tu montes ou quand je joue dans le
buste pour tous est ce que je la teste
la france et même si je prends ta tête
aux petites françaises fois savais rien
je me disais je ne citais phrase elle
faillit françois bien différent que je
parte
donc la française d'une carte l'algérien
c'est pareil puisque on dit toujours qu
à friser tu t'appelles ça le problème
essentiel incontestablement c'est le
sait le travail c'est à dire que les
jeunes actuellement on trouve pas de
travail
sur tous ces jeunes les jeunes
maghrébins jeunes maghrébins
actuellement et ils ont pas tout à fait
tort 10 si je me présente un employeur
et que je me présente alors qu'un jeune
français est un peu sortie qui se
présentent en même temps que moi je sais
que ces jeunes français qui aura la
place et c'est une réalité
par conséquent pour tous ces jeunes là
il se trouvait effectivement sans
travail alors le deuxième aspect c'est
le problème des stages et en ce qui
concerne les stages ces stages sont
partis d'un niveau intellectuel ou d'un
degré de connaissance qui sont trop
élevés par rapport à ce type de
population par conséquent
si on leur demande pour être magasinier
de savoir très bien les mathématiques et
l'orthographe
bon ben
tous ces petits maghrébins qui ont
forcément ne serait ce que par le
décalage culturel un petit retard
scolaire arrive pas à s'intégrer à ce
démarrage de ces stages par conséquent
bon ben c'est raté pour cette population
là alors ils traînent ils n'ont pas
d'avenir
ça suffit pour évidemment ces remontées
pas mal de difficultés c'est à toi par
exemple subi comment alors tu travailles
pas tu es rythme à trouver de travail
comment tu vis sont partantes prochain
jason que c'est dans ce sens que ma mère
à 1500 par jour quoi 5 3 paquets de
cigarettes
c'est tout et puis j'ai la chance que
mon père et comprend un peu le problème
il l'a compris
mais est ce que tes parents ont
suffisamment d'argent pour te donner de
l'argent de poche ça que tu travailles
suffisamment on peut pas dire ça de mon
père et frère sommitaux juge pas un
million par 20 par mois juste pour
nourrir la famille cette fois c'est le
maximum ne pas donner plus
mais dans la cité alors tu n'as pas de
travail qu'est ce que tu fais à longueur
de journée avec des camarades
qu'on a rien à faire on va la défense
puis sinon quand un ballon puis fait
beau jour sur le terrain la défense
qu'il ya en france il ya la patinoire on
se promène et la musique que tu peux
faire rien son argent condal des autres
afin de manger ou alors tu passes devant
depuis que nous la [ __ ] je regarde et
je me dis il a de l'argent ils
travaillent moi je n'ai pas je me dis ça
dans la tête et c'est de trouver des
solutions
ça fait deux ans je pas qu'on trouve une
solution
dans les allées de la cité sur les
parkings les jeunes cherchent à échapper
à l'ennui
il passe sans transition du cyclomoteur
à la bmw
quand ils ont récupéré une vieille
voiture il a réparé s'entassent dedans
et s'amuse à provoquer ce qu'ils
appellent les coeurs c'est à dire les
policiers omar chine bien hâte en
attendant les deux gardiens chaque côté
des noix en plus mais il est revenu il
travaille avec toit du palais travail
dans le toit ah je croyais pas
tous
cette provocation et permanente pour eux
c'est le moyen de montrer qu'ils
existent
on la retrouve dans leur manière de
s'exprimer nous avons rencontré michel
il est parfaitement conscient que ce
qu'il dit va renforcer le rejet dont il
est victime
nous avons ressenti cela à la fois comme
un défi et comme un appel de demandes et
tournage décalage vient d'avoir 16 ans
qu'est ce que tu fais actuellement
tellement rien
j'étais à l'école
qu'est ce que tu as fait à l'école moi
j'ai fait ma sixième après j'ai été
dégagée de l'école ce fut une année de
mécanique générale
bref une moitié j'ai été dégagée mais
j'ai fait un super gars je fais un quart
dernier j'ai été dégagée et pour attirer
dégager chaque fois piti vous sécher
l'école les cours parce que les colts
intéresse pas
mais je vais tout de suite entré dans la
vie active
mais actuellement qu'est ce que tu fais
toute la journée à nanterre bah rien on
galère qu'est ce que ça veut dire galéré
c'est quand on sait pas quoi [ __ ]
et puis on n'a pas d'argent alors on
cherche sur ce n'importe quoi gains pour
bien dire on galère on cherchait à se
débrouiller de l'argent n'importe quel
petit vol
juste de quoi les soirs boîte au cinéma
s'acheter du fiqh des conneries comme ça
vous galérez vous êtes nombreux à
galérer huawei on a beaucoup ça dépend
quand y'en a ils ont de l'argent ils
savent s'occuper quand il y en a
d'autres qui n'en n'ont pas il reste
assis devant une entrée pratiquement
toute la journée en train de fumer des
cigarettes sous le pour voler que bah tu
organises ça vous organisez sakoba la
majorité du temps ça se fait plutôt à la
sauvette
sinon comment quand c'est un petit voile
style cambrioler un appartement un truc
comme ça bon ben ça se prépare
les gars vont calculer ils vont calculer
les horaires de la femme ou du bonhomme
qu'ils habitent dans cet appartement
pour voir quand ils travaillent pas ou
des trucs comme ça pour pouvoir lui
cambriolé sinon les petits vols comme ça
ils font ça vite fait à la sauvette
puissant moins
en général j'ai de copiaco brûlé
appartenant pas majorité sont les gars
ils travaillent pas plus de trois ou
quatre des fois de majorité c'est de
voir et 4 et ça rapporterait un peu
d'argent ah ouais ça dépend des
appartements ça n'apportera rien du tout
qu'un ado que ça rapportera
ça apporte quoi
ac 1
tubize j'en achète aussi un peu de shit
il ya beaucoup de jeunes qui fument dans
de rester ouais ça doit citer pas
spécialement ce que dans toutes les
cités ça fume 1
qu'est ce ça t'apporte de fumée
j'ai mes repères wesley oublié là le
problème on rigole entre nous tous comme
ça on s'ennuie pas au moins le temps on
ne voit pas passer on est bien à quel
âge commencer à fumer
14 ans juste d'avoir 14 ans
qu'est ce qui plaît le plus dans la vie
en fait dans ta vie qu'est ce qu'il
ferait
il ya l'émouvante hurun
[Musique]
défoncée par le gie des biches avec man
on earth tour
sinon quand je me retrouve des français
[Musique]
là c'est bien là et que vous partez vous
promener comme ça est ce que vous allez
y d'emprunter des voitures c'était
toujours le soir la nuit ce qui le
minuit minuit 1h du matin
voilà jusqu'à dépendre du plein de la
voiture rial plein met en route jusqu'à
tant qu'elle soit vide on la crève
il faut pas faire évoluer comme voiture
bmw
monsieur ça
ça de la reprise c'est sport c'est
c'est confortable dedans c'est beau
quand voiture
s'avançait de la patate sinon au golf
des titres comme ça le plus longtemps
- 2/6 tc bmw
et j'ai eu des problèmes avec la police
ouais t'es tu sortes de problèmes depuis
le banc
qu'est ce qui se passe ils viennent vous
demander vos papiers il faut des
vérifications à wes à leur routine ne
nous arrête tu vous ils vous demandent
et papiers
mais tu déjà fait arrêter pour quelque
chose de précis pour un vol dans
l'espace comme en général
moi je dormais de 4l de gendarmes sont
venus mon père m'a dit lave toi ils
viennent pour toi si tu accusé de
cambriolage et 12 ils m'ont embarqué ils
ont tapé une perquisition chez moi et
puis comme vous ont rien trouvé ils ont
laissé tomber la ferme ont mis en
surveillance qui pleuraient pendant 48
heures les temps de finir l'enquète
c'est tout est déjà passé devant le juge
des enfants
ouais j'ai rendez vous aujourd'hui à
cannes
et ça se passe comment tu as pu avoir le
juge
que ce
je pense qu'ils les panneaux mis les
jugent que c'est dieu c'est trop beau et
du bon jour va nous parler
nous taper une petite morale et nous
dire ce qu'on veut faire tout ça pour
essayer de nous placer de nous
maintenant dans le bon chemin sans trop
pousser pour pas qu'on s'en aperçoive
depuis j'ai l'impression qu'ils courent
par le juge des enfants
ouais mais content on sait très bien ça
se voit quand quand il parle qui
comprend pas aussi bien que l'éducatrice
éducatrice et comprend mieux le jeune
les jeunes battant david éducatrice de
juges qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent faire
profil bas il peut faire beaucoup de
choses et des éducatrices à ma sortie de
la merde avec des pluies qui tous
autrement là qu'est ce que tu veux
attaquer tu vois comment est-ce que tu
envisages d'avenir à long terme non non
non c'est pas bien dessus peut très bien
travailler mais le fun quand il voit
et ceux qui travaillent travail pendant
huit heures par jour pendant
pendant toute la semaine qui vit ici que
ses copains ils sont cent là ils sont
contents ils foutent rien ça
mais qui a envie de travailler
non mais il faut bien se caser au bout
d'un moment
je suis très bien de ce que tu lui comme
ça je rêve à 18 ans jusqu'à l'arrivée
mon coeur comme foot à la porte d'une
dure travailles pas tu es puni j'ai plus
besoin de nourrir c'est vrai pourtant
pas ce que c'est
sans mes parents que ils vont garder
éternellement si je travaille pas il
faudra qu'ils nourrissent et tout bas
qu'est ce que je vais faire je me
retrouve à la rue que je vais faire que
des adultes et le patron avec nisshin en
envoyant la voiture
la police ne fait rien ou encore la
police ne peut rien faire
combien de fois avons nous entendu cela
au canigou un après midi nous avons donc
accompagné les policiers embarquer dans
une modeste r4 la brigade des mineurs
des hauts-de-seine
nous avons suivi les deux inspecteurs et
l'inspectrice de service ce jour-là
c'était une ronde de prévention à
travers les différentes cités de
nanterre objectif des policiers
rechercher le contact avec les jeunes
des mineurs vers autre chose
dans un cas comme celui ci la caméra
cause bien sûr le jeu mais ces dialogues
ou ses tentatives de dialogue dont nous
avons été les témoins sont paraît-il
utile on est amis cependant ces
enquêteurs qui parfois prennent des
allures d'assistantes sociales manque de
moyens pour ce travail de prévention
la brigade des mineurs des
hauts-de-seine c'est trente
fonctionnaires pour un département de 1
million cinq cent mille habitants
[Musique]
la grande partie de gendarmes et voleurs
se joue ici aux quatre temps le centre
commercial de la défense pour tous les
jeunes qui habitent dans les cités c'est
la terre promise
[Musique]
un ticket de bus ou un ticket de métro
et en quelques minutes il se retrouve au
milieu des lumières et des boutiques
loin de leur béton on va voir ce qui se
passe là juste là
[Musique]
pardon
comment
est-ce pas là
dtc
ceux qui ont de l'argent si éclate
s'amuse si vous préférez pour les autres
traîner aux quatre temps c'est une autre
forme de la galère
un soir nous avons vu une bande de
gosses d'étaler après avoir cassé une
vitrine
cependant la plupart du temps les
chapardages commis aux quatre temps sont
de petits chapardage c'est leur
répétition qui provoquent l'exaspération
des adultes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon briquet
je pense que tu es
cette entrée qu'en france mais même à
tous et sur l'eau
[Musique]
les jeunes de leur côté se sentent
encore plus frustré surtout lorsqu'ils
n'arrivent pas à s'incruster comme ils
disent traduisait à entrer dans
l'immense boîte de nuit ouverte jusqu'à
6 heures du matin l'entrée de 60 francs
mais il faut être accompagné
et quand on vient d'une cité sortir une
fille ce n'est pas non plus évident
pendant ce temps dehors la police
multiplie les contrôles sur les passages
obligés entre paris et la banlieue
il s'agit de stopper la progression de
la drogue vers les sites est un fléau
qui a gagné du terrain ces derniers mois
au passage non pas tactique
ça pas d'appétit vtec a pas fumer c'est
pas à cause de ça puisque chance qu'on
fera tout le temps que ça bête abattue
port breton et un bal sur toi et toi tu
vas en acheter mais c'est pas toujours
au sima samar et cinq semaines mais
c'est le passé on se fait déjà et a déjà
été été figé mais c'est déjà un an que
j'ai besoin de temps et je me suis fait
arrêter aussi avec sa fille à paris
c'est comme ça fait trois semaines trois
semaines et la danse
bon comme il faut
vous croyez moi je réponds palais
et la pause c'était quatre pôles c'est
du porno chic à combien de sniff par
jour un chrome pour préparer chevaux et
il convient le gramme ou la chine 600
francs donc 600 francs par jour mais 600
francs d'argent vous fallait louer et
comment vous les obtenir j'ai revendu
tous mes bijoux
j'avais alors que j'ai eu depuis le ch
était tout petit
[Musique]
mais ce que ça a changé les rapports
même des jeunes intérieurs dhs a cité le
fait qu'un est certain qu'ils se
droguent beaucoup énormément énormément
même ça a changé en gros parce que il ya
un temps à la cité et si si même même
tous les jeunes se rassemblaient tous
autant qu'on est on se rassemblait tous
mettez la en vénétie ont discuté de
choses et donc on avait au fond au
terrain de foot on a trouvé c'est pas
une équipe pour trouver ont trouvé dix
équipes dix équipes pour jouer c'est
arrivé d'éclat drogue est arrivé trouve
plus personne
on sait plus avec qui discuter au plus
bas et on peut pas y aller dit tu pas si
on peut discuter avec un mec qui se
droguent nous on les connaît on a
l'habitude de les voir peut discuter
avec lui mais quand il soutient la
tendance a pas vouloir discuter parce
qu'il est bien dans sa peau une et
l'autre pas actuellement la majorité des
gens qu'on reçoit à partir de l'âge de
12 13 ans c'est triste à dire c'est à
cause des problèmes de drogue et je ne
parle pas des drones 12 ça parce qu'ils
ont fait ces laissez-passer nocifs mais
surtout des hommes durs mais lestée de
cocaïne héroïne
et la majorité des jeunes de 13 14 15
ans qui vont en prison c'est à cause de
ça parce qu'il quitte pour avoir grandi
avec la prison c'est l'engrenage ensuite
serre qui ne trouvent pas de travail non
plus est ce que la prison est une
réponse à leurs problèmes et c'est pour
nous ça n'est sûrement pas une mais eux
ils s'en foutent parce que c'est des
gens qui finalement sont arrivés à un
moment où ils sont complètement
indifférent 10 qui les entoure donc il
n'aura plus de sentiments on va se
rencontrer un jeune de 13 ans était à
l'époque où le tribunal de nanterre il
ya eu la loire où même les gens de maïté
saison ils peuvent aller en prison pour
une durée de dix jours qui faisait de la
prison enfin une semaine sur l'autre et
finalement ils s'en foutent complètement
aux idées à l'intérieur ou à l'extérieur
pour moi c'est pareil je préfère sortir
faire un petit coup avoir trois quatre
mille balles de dépenser pour retourner
en prison
enfin ils n'ont plus de sentiments
humains
les sensations pour ça
[Musique]
saïd abid la dernière hlm au nord de la
cité aux confins de nanterre et de pau
lons c'est un personnage important au
canigou
il est l'ami de tous les jeunes il
condamne la drogue
il ne refuse jamais son aide aux copains
en difficulté vers la fin du reportage
il nous a expliqué que lui-même avait
été deux fois en prison j'en attrape les
voleurs les condamne mais cherche pas à
savoir pourquoi ils ont fait ça doit
combattre est emprisonné barrage était
pour un cambriolage quoi les deux fois
la première fois m'accuser de choses que
nous ne mettions pas dire quoi il ya
deuxième poteau rue la chérie de ses
commettants prison mais que tous va
apporter la prison et que ça porte à un
jeune qui et quand il va en prison est
ce que tu es sorti de là différents que
cette apporté jeudi pour moi ça ça m'a
apporté quelque chose parce que j'ai vu
comment j'ai souffert parce que beau
dire j'ai souffert mais on a d'autres
qui ne passeront trois ans quatre ans
puis s'arrête pas c'est peut-être
indices cet avis moi pour ma bon pour
l'avenir je ne peux pas dire ce qui va
se passer parce que seul dieu le sait
mais actuellement je sais que je serai
pas recommencer parce que maintenant ça
m'a suffit tu es à la requête est
toujours au chômage c'est pas de travail
c'est à dire que par exemple si tu
arrive de faire un autre cambriolage dit
maintenant tu risques combien je peux
prendre un deux ou trois ans facile
parce que pour eux
punition c'est simple ça se passe comme
ça je te donne trois mois
c'est un avertissement c'est la première
fois que donne trois mois deux mois on
si tu reviens ils te donnent un petit 6
mois et s'il voit que tu reviennes
troisième fois alors italie a dit ne pas
comprendre les ballons on va le faire
comprendre et croire que les gens
comprennent et justement les délinquants
empire en gros je crois que j'aime
délinquants comprendre
quand y comprend rien ils sont maître
tant qu'on est dedans ils sont maîtres
ils sont maîtres de nous une fois qu'on
est à l'extérieur ils ont pu mettre va
pas voir qu'on va faire saïd a sept
frères et une soeur
il habite cet appartement de cinq pièces
pour un loyer de 1200 francs par mois
les enfants en âge de travailler sont au
chômage la mère est femme de service le
matin l'après-midi elle fait des ménages
elle quitte la cité à 6h du matin elle
revient le soir à 9h pour 3000 francs
par mois
c'est le seul salaire qui rentre dans la
maison saïd est sorti de prison il ya
deux mois
actuellement deux autres de ses frères
sont à fleury mérogis j'ai la danse et
une fois par semaine moi je n'ai 5 go
moi je trouve pas en baisse de 21 je
croyais à 5 9 3 pour 1 va devoir à 19
ans il a passé a besoin parce qu'ils
vont vous m'excusez défaut qu'il a droit
de sortir avec une fille ella droit de
rentrer dans le café la demande
d'acheter une chose qui vaudra il trouve
il n'a rien du tout il n'y a pas de
travail et rien du tout c'est normal que
ça fait des bêtises ou présent
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait s'envoler pas
de travail et vos fils qui sont reprises
or est ce que vous avez le temps d'aller
les voir je n'ai pas pourquoi je
travaille toute la journée je peux pas
je vais aussi le fusion c'est parce je
ne peux pas m'avancer je ne souhaite pas
qu'orange et de le voir là bas au
présent je n'ai pas du tout de quoi
générer nulle part mais god sommes
présents comment est ce que vous pouvez
voir l'avenir de vos enfants dans cette
cité actuellement j'ai peur même si
tranchée père parce que comment l'un
d'eux au présent j'ai peur d'eux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
eh ben je n'aimerais pas de tomber sur
un gars qui touche à nos maisons pas aux
turcs à son appartement où ils cassent
tout cas parce que là je pense je
voulais lui faire sa fête et je crois
que ça fait
le vin est bonne parce que je lis sur
balles est passé en huit mois j'ai dû
quand même pas en arriver là mais lui en
paix lui rappelant de travailler et à
vivre honnêtement tout le monde est ce
qu'il ya des groupes de défense ici eh
ben on n'est pas prêts dans on n'est pas
loin d'en faire parce qu'on en a marre
on n'est pas protégé
on n'a pas de deux agents de police y
ont leur peau il ya des gens prêts à
tirer ben je le sent on le sent mes
enfants ne souhaite pas on souhaite pas
en arriver là et ça alors qu'est ce que
ça vous a montré ça tout haut eh ben
c'est ce sont des des matraques qui ont
été faites par des gens comme omar et
qui veulent sûrement s'en servir un jour
le jour on sur la table à l'arrivée d'un
bolide
vous êtes le premier c'est vraiment une
route d'arriver là où vous en avez une
matraque non moi je pouvais mais il ya
des gens on les distribue alors les gens
on se défendra voyez n'est pas mal de
distribuer déjà mais je pense qu'une
bonne crosse de fusil ça fait beaucoup
de mal coups de matraque
mais dites moi c'est très bon joueur je
vous dis pas ça ça tu es un gars peur
peut faire beaucoup de bêtises et il en
fera sûrement le jour tout ce qu'on a pu
voir c'est la peur qui a dit qu'à qui a
incité les gens à se défendre c'est pas
l'udc c'est pas du courage c'est la peur
comme si vous êtes m
c'est quoi ça va ça vous que les
festayres se retourne enfin c'est à la
demande de certains jeux éclatés
si l'on rase entreposés chez moi si vous
voulez mais je ne suis pas je ne suis
pas l'instigateur de la chose mais
disons que certains locataires en
demander à monsieur qui travaillent dans
la maison qui fabrique ces câbles de
leur procurer des morceaux de 50
centimes pour faire des matraques mais
vous pouvez tuer avec ça disons que non
on va tout dépend comment on s'en sert
il faut pas taper sur la tête évidemment
mais si on tape sur la clavicule série
seul à faire des dégâts au niveau de la
clavicule lyon ça ne peut que blessé
connaissons-nous pas taper sur la tête
et alors bientôt les locataires vont se
promener avec ça surtout la nuit
surtout la ligue quand il se déplace sur
le parquet mais quand en plus le parking
n'est pas éclairée ils sont pas sont pas
tranquille avec ça ils se sentent plus
sur deux voiliers certes avec ça dans
les mains ou dissimulés dans la dans le
un manteau dans nos blousons il
dissimule bien sûr ils se promènent pas
avec ça à la main et 6 600 régresser
forcément ils vont taper ça c'est sûr
c'est pour vous dire à quel point les
gens sont sont inquiets ce qu'il
faudrait pas c'est que la population
française en général se crispe sur ses
peurs se crispe sur cette espèce de
montée de la violence qu'on a quand même
un petit peu fabriqué vous le dire
et du coup renforce cette spirale
en excluant davantage qui entraînera
plus de violence qui entraînera plus
d'exclusion on s'en sortira pas donc je
crois qu'ils veulent c'est très
important d'arriver à briser de ce cycle
si on ne brise pas je sais pas on ira
on était parti avec 43 % d'augmentation
de détention des mineurs n'allait
dernière donc on ne peut pas dire qu'il
ait un accident au contraire moi je veux
dire c'est sans fin c'est sans fin parce
que plus on va exclure
et plus on va avoir de violence et c'est
cela que nous voulons éviter jusqu alors
un enterrement
compte tenu de la politique de la
municipalité qui était toujours une
politique d'apaisement et de recherche
de compréhension des différentes
communautés
nous sommes parvenus à éviter le pire et
je pense que nous pouvons parvenir à
continuer pour continuer à éviter le
pire
nous sommes pas garantie contre cela on
a démoli les bidonvilles on a construit
des cités
faut-il maintenant démolir ces cités
d'autres disent qu'il faut démolir
comment est-ce qu'on va s'en sortir
comment est-ce qu'on commence à s'en
sortir par exemple sur la cité des 4000
à bobigny c'est parce qu'on a réduit le
nombre d'habitants et qu'il ya un
certain nombre de logements vacants
qu'on va laisser je crois qu'il faut
casser briser ces grandes cités parce
que sans ça on s'en sortira pas
condamner les yeux comme si le bruit des
pelleteuses prouvait d'un seul coup
effacé le chômage de mustapha la couleur
de la peau de sayid la hargne des
boulistes tout ce que nous avons
recueillis en une semaine ordinaire de
balade du côté de la cité des cadets
bout
[Musique]